so lima yes as we just saw with amanda
um she's a different person
yeah you've transformed amanda because
our team is really good at what we do
i think you knew what you were doing all
along yep um
so just just give us a little synopsis
of what was involved in amanda's
rehab and why it's been so successful
absolutely
so amanda was traumatized on a regular
basis while she was living on skid row
and a lot of times when people are in
that environment and they can't escape
that environment
the reason that it's called mental and
behavioral health is because
when they can't express themselves they
start to act out how they feel
and so the case with amanda
she was you know as you had described
some of the horrific circumstances where
you'd constantly have to
buy her clothes and you'd find her
without clothes again there was a
there was you know plus the abuse and
the physical violence
as i've said before she was the worst
case you could find on skid row
yeah definitely and probably the worst
case i've ever seen personally
it took a lot of courage for you to
decide that she was the one you wanted
to try to help
yeah but you know we have a lot of
confidence in what we do and i really
truly don't believe in an impossible
case i think that
this just goes to show you not to give
up on anybody
but um the the core factor is that
amanda's not a miracle
it's just a very structured system of
how to do things and if we can do this
for everybody we can save
anyone yeah i really believe that now
because when we first started i was i
was like oh man this is
this could go this could go badly
definitely and
i was i was amazed at how together
amanda is now
she's so clear-headed she's so present
it's amazing
amanda walks up to the other patients
when she realizes that someone's new and
she'll go and introduce herself
and and let them know that if they need
anything to
come out and reach out to her um and
there's been several instances where
people have given her things and
she's gone out of her way to share those
those items
even some of the items that were gifts
that were sent to her from
you guys she was sharing them one of the
girls didn't she only had one pair of
shoes in the treatment center
and so she gave her a pair of shoes or
she was giving clothes to people that
didn't have
so she's definitely just
her true character has completely come
out
in all of this and she feels so blessed
that she wants to share that with other
people so
i think that that's been it's been the
most wonderful thing to work with her
and one of the most incredible things
has been how many letters she's
received she shared with me on multiple
occasions that's
that that's one of her biggest
motivators and
because there's been so many people that
have said that they're going to
treatment because of amanda
because they've seen her transform her
life
amanda and i decided to do a video a day
in the life
of so what it's actually like to go to
treatment for a day
because i also get a tremendous amount
of people reaching out saying that
they're
scared to go to treatment or they don't
want to feel like they're in jail they
can't do what they want to do
um so we did that together and i can
link that on my instagram
if anyone wants to see it but but yeah
that was really really incredible
and she definitely took charge and
explained
what goes on but i think at this point
she feels like a staff member because
she's been there for a while
so she finishes everybody's sentences
before they
when they're explaining a therapy or a
technique
yeah so in a nutshell the reason
amanda's
rehab has been so successful
is why because she was re
removed from a traumatic environment
for a sustained period of time so all of
a sudden
you take someone who all the life that
they know
i'm i'm not good enough for this this is
where i
am and um she couldn't imagine
what her life could actually be like and
at the very beginning like
the two problems that addicts have or
anybody like even workaholics or
whatever the case is
setting boundaries so the inability to
say no to take on extra projects or
to say no to drugs or to say no to
sexual advances whatever it is setting
boundaries
and the second thing is being okay and
happy with yourself
and um you can't do that in 30 days
so at the very beginning when you're
telling someone that they're worth it
that they deserve better that they can
forgive themselves
for experiences that may necessarily not
have been them
their fault so amanda with the sexual
abuse and
the drug abuse
plus the mental illness in my opinion
having sex with someone that's mentally
ill is the equivalent of having sex with
a child like someone that
is unable to make decisions and is
completely disoriented with drugs
it's really an important for them and
then they end up feeling disgusted by
themselves
because of what happened it's really
important for those people to understand
it's not your fault you were taken
advantage of
and you're worthy of something better
and so at the very beginning
their brain is like okay i hear what
you're saying i'll say
i love myself and good things about
myself but they don't actually believe
it
and amanda being in an environment for
seven months where she hasn't been able
to use
she hasn't been able to be abused and
she's been in a place where people are
constantly telling her that they're so
proud of her
she's constantly receiving letters from
all over the world saying
that they are so honored that she's
willing to share her story and change
other people's lives and also that
um she's making a lot of friends so
in the video that we shot her roommate
really wanted to be
in a part of it so i got a release form
for her
but her roommate was also shared how
amanda was really helping other people
there
so it's been really incredible to see
her take
all the positive words that everyone's
been sharing and then she shares them
with
with others yeah it's a beautiful story
definitely tell me i mean
we talked about this in one of the
earlier videos but for people that
maybe are new to the story tell me how
you started aura and why
yeah so i started aura because my
sisters who are identical twins have had
some mental health
struggles they were diagnosed with
dissociative identity disorder which is
more commonly known as
multiple personality disorder and they
were misdiagnosed with schizophrenia for
over three and a half years given the
wrong medication
and developed an addiction to
prescription medications
um so i've struggled a lot that's
devastated my family and we've gone into
a lot of details in the first video so i
won't go into those
right now but um
my biggest mission with this is to
raise the bar for mental health care
because my sisters
have each been to over 60 treatment
centers and nothing's worked because
they're all 30-day short-term stays
and of course to afford forty five
thousand dollars on average
times two for a prolonged period of time
like what we're doing for amanda
is um not something that the average
family can afford to do
so it becomes who can afford to get
better and that's
that's the core issue with our mental
health care system
and then when you have so many patients
there for such short terms
and they're all very agitated and
depressed
and stressed out they end up being
sedated in these facilities
and so you end up with a situation where
they're pumped full of meds for 30 days
released go crazy because they've lost
total support
and they also are cut off from so many
medications
and then they end up using and relapsing
and so it ends
it's it's a vicious cycle there's not 90
relapse rate um one of the biggest
problems for me
specifically is the stigma with mental
health a lot of people don't talk about
it
and for a really long time i hid it from
friends and and
actually also family members my mom and
my sisters just kind of
were very quiet about what was going on
and
it's a huge problem because so many
people don't understand it
and for example with
my sisters having did it was
it was um there was an incident where i
went to a friend's wedding in chicago
and um i was living and taking care of
my sisters at the time so i had
i was going i was going for a few days
and i got a phone call from my sisters
that they were having seizures and they
couldn't stop
and at the time i didn't know what these
seizures were but i found out that they
are called pseudo-seizures
they're caused by severe psychological
and mental distress
and i ended up video calling them
for about nine hours
and i was trying to convince them to go
to to let me call the police so i'd be
interacting with the people at the
wedding and smiling and acting like
everything was okay
and then i'd go into the room and i
would check
you know my phone because both my mom
and i were on this video call for nine
hours
eventually they agreed to let me call
the police because of course
having additional people there could
make the pseudo seizures even worse
so once they agree to that i called the
police and i thought that everything
would be okay
and my sisters thought immediately
or the police thought immediately that
my sisters were faking it because it
didn't look like a seizure that
they knew and um and
they threatened to arrest my sisters and
i was on the phone
listening to all of this and then as
soon as that happened
their altar switched and then the police
didn't even understand what dissociative
identity disorder was
and they thought that they were faking
it and they were just calling 9-1-1 to
mess around
and so i spent another two hours that
day on the phone with police trying to
get them to release my sisters because
they wanted to arrest them for
abusing 9-1-1 and faking this and so
this has also happened at numerous
hospitals where
staff just thinks that if they've gone
in
because they're afraid of what's going
on with them mentally
the staff is not really trained in the
emergency room to handle mental
distress so they end up thinking that my
sisters are faking it
and it becomes a huge problem so the
stigma factor
is really really important for me to
just get people talking about it and
understanding it
all right so bam and nikki marchera
you probably know them from jackass they
were so
moved by amanda's story that they've
pledged to help support this publicly
and help me fundraise for
amanda and for the scholarship to help
raise more money
so in order to say thank you to them
our team has a bunch of virtual cities
in our inside our virtual reality
system so we made a billboard for them
and that was on the skid row experience
that we put amanda in
and if you want to check that out that's
also on instagram with their handles as
well if you guys want to support them
but the reason that this is so
incredibly significant is because
bam actually recently went to a
treatment center
um he was he went in for adderall and
alcohol
and he was very much vocal about the
fact that
he came out addicted to over 10
different medications
the difference between what we did for
amanda and
bam's experience is that treatment
centers that are using
tools like aura to actually measure and
track patients
feelings and identify which patients are
better suited for group which patients
are better suited for
one-on-one therapy and also be able to
provide individualized support
means that they can be more responsible
with medication so they don't have to
sedate everybody because they're
tracking everyone through the technology
and
i think that that's a huge factor um
and so the last thing is that i've had
an overwhelming amount of people
reaching out for the lps conservatorship
template
so i it was really important to me that
instead of everybody waiting for a
response from me
we've put everything up on our website
so that way
you guys can find those under resources
and
if you're a healthcare provider that
wants to integrate tools into your
practice you can find you can email us
at
healthcare meet aura dot io and if
you're
a family member that's looking for
support you can either check out our
website
or you can also send an email to
familysupport
me aura dot io our goal is to make
to make sure that mental health is
treated like physical health
and it's really important to us that
everyone feels like they're getting
the same type of support that amanda's
getting
and so lastly if you are able to donate
to the gofundme campaign so that we can
continue
covering amanda's care um and
we can also if it gets big enough we can
actually start
accepting more people including some of
the viewers that are watching this
that's the goal
that would be excellent that would be a
dream come true yeah
we've done an incredible job with amanda
yeah thank you so much
i think i think you may have changed the
direction of how
rehab should hopefully the the world
will see how rehab should
go differently than than it does
currently definitely we need to
we need to bring these rehab facilities
into the 21st century
it's really exciting and it's really
transforming the industry and it's using
technology that's
being used in gaming or being used in
fintech and
pushing it into mental health care so
it's it's really
a game changer yeah so great for
amanda and her dad and and maybe many
other people
definitely all right lina thank you so
much thank you mark